et vous l'avez vu dans ce sujet jean
michel fourgous le maire d'elancourt et
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines étaient présents pour ce rendez
vous nous avons profité de l'occasion
pour évoquer avec lui la succession de
michel laugier fraîchement élue au sénat
à la tête de l'agglomération jean michel
fourgous a remporté cette semaine une
élection interne à la droite et sera
ainsi le candidat de la majorité
il a donc de fortes chances de devenir
le nouveau président de saint quentin en
yvelines
on l'écouté home est créé au micro
d'aurélie rose ça se présente bien où
j'ai beaucoup de mes collègues élus
voilà qui qui qui qui jouent le jeu en
plus moi qui m'ont dit que l'on y voyait
pas ce que c'est normal il y avait
plusieurs tendances mai
qui veut tron normalement puisque on est
quand même majoritaire de tout ça sent
bon bien sûr mais non je suis optimiste
deux ou trois c'est la vie et
démocratique cgt dit peut-être avant de
mettre 500 sony cd plus d'accord sur les
choses j'ai vécu ça met le ballon il ya
une vraie tendance